Franken says if he was still in the Senate he'd press Kavanaugh, in two key areas.
I bet he would, thanks Ed.
Our top story tonight: the President's tweeting
we'll dispel the silly notion we're deliberately misleading.
Plus, people are outraged at Starbucks' holiday cup.
We'll have the fiery backlash as the program picks up.
Huh, who's outraged?
The world is embittered!
No really, who's outraged?
Two people on Twitter.
Look we want to disprove the President's tweets,
maybe no holiday cups.
I see what you mean.
So again, our top story, enemy of the people?
Trump's ridiculous claim that we view you as sheeple.
Plus, people are outraged at Starbucks' unity cup-
That's not what I meant.
-backlash and why some are fed up.
72% of people think that what we do is misleading
isn't playing up an outrage just a bit self defeating.
I know that we've honed in on what's good for ratings,
but enough with the cups!
I understand what you're saying.
Deadly protests in Nicaragua with Ortega in charge
what the latest crackdown means for the region at large.
Plus, people are outraged at Starbucks' new mug-
Not cups specifically!
No, again, our top story a white house deranged?
CNN's Jim Acosta in a testy exchange.
And so we don't lose your trust, we'll sit silent, alone
and go straight to an eyewitness live on the phone.
Well Jim Acosta asked a question right at the start
it was a very good question, really quite smart.
Some here said he had a knack for unmasking impostors.
And your name for the record?
Jim Acosta.
Oh my God.
Finally we leave on a note that is somber,
as noun verb outrage preposition
The template's in the prompter!
preposition Starbucks adjective noun.
Preposition verb backlash preposition pronoun.